- So, what?
We're in Orlando for five hours?
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
(upbeat big band music)
- [Gary] How are ya?
'Sup man?
Good to see ya.
Morning, how are you?
- [Woman] Good. How are you?
- [Gary] Good.
Checking in.
Thank you so much.
Oh, I'm the road half
the year, so I'm used to it.
Yeah, I missed it.
I landed Sunday morning.
- [Woman 2] You have
some deodorant on your shirt.
- [Gary] Yeah. No worries.
- [Woman 2] Okay.
- [Gary] The level of me giving
a shit is at an all-time low.
(Woman 2 laughs)
Super excited to be here at ICR.
A conference in Orlando that
I've actually done maybe four of
the last six years,
five of the last seven years.
It's an investors conference
where Wall Street comes together
with emerging CPG
and restaurant groups.
It's a really fun conference for
me because as a lot of you know
my big goal over time is
eventually only brands and buy
them and flip them and trade
them and this is an absolute
conference where
the banking world,
the Wall Street world,
the emerging CPGs and
fast casual restaurant
groups are coming
and some of the
big guys and gals as well
and so I always have
a little bit of extra pep
to my step when I'm at
this conference because
I know that so many of the
people in this room are people
that I'm going to
be sitting across from
in board meetings
over the next decade,
two, three, four decades and
so that brings some energy, too.
A lot of people here
don't believe in the world
that I believe in.
A lot of people
here are data people.
And data people in the way of
using data to tell you what
happened instead
of doing what I do
which is looking at intuition
and then, you know kind of
different kinds of data and
interpreting tone
and using my magic to
predict what gonna happen.
And so, a lot of times
when I give talks here,
I get a lot of people very
excited about what I'm saying
and a lot of people that
want to punch me in the throat.
And I think that's exactly how
I like it best
because when I talk
and when I think
about the world,
I think about it in...
Good to see you again.
I think about it
in two ways;
One, either I want them
to completely love it or
two, I want them to
completely hate it because
at the end I'm gonna win.
- [Speaker] So we think 6 weeks
of national TV focused in the
first quarter
will be game changing.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Speaker] Game changing level
of advertising that will drive
this virtuous cycle
and will drive momentum.
And momentum will then drive
more advertising and we will
then be able to accelerate the
move that you heard Wayne Stocks
and others really transition
from local spend to national.
This is our first...
- [Gary] I'm buying and
creating all the capabilities.
If you just looked at
the hands in this room,
and this is a small focus group
but I don't think anybody's
confused by this and even if
my brands that spend tens of
billions of dollars to make a
30 second video to compel you to
buy something that
nobody on Earth anymore consumes
whatsoever even if your remote
control falls off your bed and
you can't fast
forward that commercial,
everybody in this room grabs
this and checks their work,
tweets about what LeBron
just said and on and on and on.
My friends, every single brand
here today is throwing a lot of
money in the
trash in two places.
Commercials, TV commercials
and what I call for
traditional digital advertising.
Buying programmatic banner ads
and pre-rolls across the web
that nobody on Earth
is consuming as well.
Thank you, guys.
Have a great year.
(audience applause)
...Years and other platforms,
you know when you're ABC,
NBC and CBS and it's 1982,
you have 25% market
share for your TV show.
When cable comes along
there's fragmentation.
Twitter was, it was
Twitter, Facebook.
And they had a lot of attention
but then as Instagram and
Snapchat came and
they didn't innovate.
Listen, they did an interesting
OTT play in
buying all these rights.
- [Man] Yes.
- If I was, if we're
talking stock market,--
- [Man] Yeah.
- and I had $40 million to
put the work against the seven
social networks,
I'd put all 40,
and I mean all
of it, on Facebook.
(light music)
- [Man 2] My brother, I want
to use you for business.
They didn't.
My dad's old school, right?
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- [Man 2] Wants to
stick with his ways.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- [Man 2] And every time
I push something different,
it's kind of a thing of he
wants to go a different way.
- There's only
one way this ends up,
you know that, right?
- Exactly. I know.
- Either you leave or you stay.
- Exactly.
So I'm wondering, I'm 25.
- You got time.
One thing I'll tell you, is the
years I spent with my dad,--
- Mhmmm.
- were things that I
could never get back.
- Yes.
- So you got to think
about that and you've got time.
But that being
said, if you want--
- I mean do I take the leap
and try to start my own company?
- Probably.
You just have to think
about, the answer's yes.
- Yeah.
- You need to have
the conversation,--
- Mhmmm.
- but you need
to have the timing.
- We've been trying to
have the conversation.
- No, no, no, no.
You walk in and
say, "Dad, I'm leaving."
- Okay.
- Will then make
him have a countermove.
- Okay.
- Which will either be,
"Okay, tough shot,
go fucking show me."
- Yeah.
- And/or "Oh, okay, wait.
Why don't you stay?
"Let's do some of that stuff."
- Okay.
- But when you
go and say I'm out,
you need to be ready.
What we've done for four
years is built an algorithm
internally to really understand
who's overpriced
and who's underpriced.
- [Woman 3] Really
appreciate it.
- Bye Ron! Take
care of yourself.
- Great talking, Gary.
- [Gary] Such a pleasure.
- [Man 3] Thanks.
- [Gary] Thanks for having me.
- [Man 3] Appreciate it.
- [Gary] Take care.
Hello.
- Hello, hello!
- One of the things
I need to expand on
in a 2017 marketing
conversation is the variable
of Facebook
creative in it's ROI.
Something that is,
I'm tapping into is that 90% of
digital execution is garbage.
(laughs) No worries at all.
No worries at all.
It's nice to connect.
Well, first of all
any time a lot of people,
anytime those
kind of trends happen,
I get more excited, right?
I tend to, yeah, I'm a
contrarian by nature, you know?
Obviously I've, my whole career,
I got into the internet business
when people
thought it was a fad.
I bought into social
media long before anybody did.
I'm now pushing
radio advertising
when that seems weird.
So I'm very comfortable in,
I could care
less what everybody
else is doing and so
and the other thing is look,
I don't view VaynerSports as the
economical differentiator
in my professional career.
So, a lot of a lot
of what's happening
from VaynerSports
standpoint has a whole lot to do
more with my heart and
my brain over my wallet.
Now that being said, you
know, that being said Liz,
I fully plan on
intending to build
the premier sports
representation
business in the world.
I don't get into
something for kicks and giggles.
Also let you know because you
know there's a lot of big agents
at CAA and Roc Nation that like
text me every day and wished
that I picked them
and they came with books.
Liz, I want to, listen, you've
been around this a long time.
I'm a big boy, you're a big girl
like these agents can do better
for these kids and the reason
Brian and Mook were attractive
to me is they have much bigger
hearts than maybe they have
wallets but the good news is
I'm the biggest
fucking shark of all,
I'll take care of the rest.
(light music)
That's insane.
- And I'm like, so
I just talked to my wife.
I'm like, "How do I
give this card back to her?
"Let her know that it's safe?
"She's on a plane
in Fort Lauderdale."
- Go to her Instagram, go
to the top right corner,--
- Okay.
- And the three little dots,
hit send message,
take a picture of it,
send her a message.
That's what you do.
- I will do that.
- Take care, man.
- Pleasure meeting you.
- [Gary] Real nice
meeting you. Stay well.
- You're changing lives, man.
Keep it up.
- [Gary] I'm trying.
Stay well, man.
- Can I say
something really quickly?
- [Gary] Yes.
- So you bought my
tickets at Beyonce and
we sat next to each other.
- Yes, we did.
Your--
- My wife works for PureWow.
- PureWow, which we just bought.
I remember, man.
- And so congratulations.
- Thank you, man.
- I just saw Ryan at CES.
- You know what's crazy?
You're a big time creative
director of sorts, right?
I know, you're
gonna play it humble.
So we were already far
in the deal that night.
So my wife and I just sit down
to Beyonce and I start talking
to your wife and I'm like,
"Oh, this is really funny."
- That's so funny.
- And things of that nature.
- And she's so excited.
- So I'm just talking to Ryan
about her and then he told me a
little bit about you and I did a
little homework so it's really
nice to meet you, man, again.
- It's nice to meet
you and congratulations.
- Thanks, man. I'm
really excited about it.
- Awesome, dude.
- I'll see you very soon.
I'm sure I'll
see you. Take care.
- [DRock] Uh,
it's getting weird.
- [Gary] Yeah.
Totally.
- [DRock] Let's uh...
(laughs)
- You feel like it's time.
- [DRock] I do.
- There's nothing I hate on
Earth more than you
trying to produce me.
- [DRock] I know, but I actually
have a good question I think.
- Okay, fine.
- [DRock] People make
excuses about that they don't
have enough
time for social media,
you're the busiest
man on Earth yet you
find your pockets.
- Right.
- [DRock] Advice?
- I'm not, there's people,
single parents raising
multiple kids plenty busy.
I'm busy. I'm real busy.
So, I'm comfortable with that.
Just comes down to wanting it.
You know, the
reason so many of you,
A-list celebrities,
B-list celebrities,
A-list and B-list social media
celebrities don't engage with
their fans and use
being busy as an
excuse is because you don't
actually want to
engage with them.
You actually don't care.
You're playing a width game
versus a depth game and so,
you know, I find my pockets
because your actions
speak louder than words.
If you want
something, you do it.
I used to say that I couldn't
work out because I was too busy.
How could I have that
hour and a half every day?
'Cause it not only
working out, it was 15 minutes,
15 minutes. You know.
I just didn't have it.
I had it.
I just didn't want it.
Made an excuse,
didn't care about it.
And so, truth is that
90-something percent of people
that are able to
amass a fan base of any size
are stunningly not appreciative.
There's so many of you that
hit me up on Instagram DM daily,
how I build a fan base?
And I go look your content and
you actually have seven fans and
you've never engaged with them.
You fucking take them for
granted 'cause
you're fucking fancy.
'Cause you don't want
to put in the work because
you think you're somebody.
Fuck that.
That's why you're losing.
You deserve to lose.
(light music)
That's how we do it,
I guess, huh?
It's a whole new world.
Alright, I'll see
you in a little bit.
Hmmm, let's go to Foot Locker.
Barney, it's GaryVee.
How are you?
This is super ironic, I'm a
little bit early for a meeting
and I'm actually walking
into a Foot Locker right now.
(light music)
These are cool.
Have you seen these?
You see these?
What?
Yeah, it's cool, right?
(laughs)
The amount of pleasure
I get from the competitive
nature of business is so insane.
Love, love this whole game.
Just so fuckin' focused.
I'm antsy to get the
fuck out of this store.
Like let's get these two pairs
and get the fuck out of here.
(DRock laughs)
I like those pairs.
I'm fired up.
Got some new sneakers.
I'll see you later, DRock.
Going into a meeting now with
Facebook and Steve Babcock,
our Chief Creative Officer.
It's fun to watch
the day after day.
You can see the cadence of it
and then I'm gonna go and see
Willie Morris
from FaithBox, the CEO.
Sorry about that.
Audio might not
have been on point,
gonna see Phil Toronto.
Then I'm gonna try to get home
at least at a somewhat decent
time, 10:30 or so, 11:00,
10:30, 11:00
'cause I have a 6 A.M.
work out 'cause we're trying to
cram a shit load in to tomorrow.
So grinding.
Alright, another
business meeting.
Ooh, you're documenting too.
- [Willie] I am documenting.
I just hit a
thousand subscribers,
not quite a million
like your Instagram.
- [Gary] I'm proud of you.
Give me some love.
- I'll give you a little love.
- [Gary] Phil.
How was Orlando?
- It was nice.
- [Gary] And
you weren't with me,
you were doing
your Disney thing?
- Yep. Disney thing.
- [Gary] How many, how many
times have you been to Disney?
- The 35th trip I think.
- [Gary] Did you just say 3-5?
- 3-5.
- [Gary] 35?
- More times
than I've been alive.
- [Gary] And when you first
started working with me you used
to drive because
you're scared of flying.
- The first year that I worked
with you was the second flight
I had ever taken.
- [Gary] And then
through my insanity of flying,
you just got comfortable
and decided flying was okay?
- That and whiskey.
- [Gary] And just
grew up as a human being?
- Yeah. Right.
- [Gary] Yeah.
(light music)